foreign
I want to talk a little bit about an
interaction that I've been having with
Scott Adams many people in the replies
to this interaction have alleged that
Scott is acting disingenuously that he
is not functioning in good faith I don't
know I don't see that in what he's
saying but maybe it's true it doesn't
matter what I want to do is recognize
that his questions to me actually
constitute a fantastic opportunity
whether they're genuine or not and I
sincerely hope that they are genuine but
whether they're genuine or not they do
lead us to exactly the right questions
that we need to be asking they speak in
a sense for an audience that is
skeptical of us but might listen alright
so Zach if you would put up the uh
thread that we have most recently been
interacting in
all right so here we have
Scott Adams so this is obviously
continuing from a different thread but
he says it's binary Brett either you
have a secret way of knowing the future
of long covid and also long-term vax
injury or you guessed about the risks
same as I did he's responding he's quote
tweeting me saying you are setting up
the problem incorrectly Scott Adams
um putting your future self and your
followers at unnecessary Risk by doing
so if you'd like to discuss it I'm
willing assuming you'd rather know than
not know that is
okay my response to his uh claim that
I'm guessing I say as I said you are
setting up the problem incorrectly it's
not a guess it's priors weightings and
evidence and then in parentheses hint
evidence is not synonymous with quote
data on a quote
it this can be explained well
but that is a very small fraction of the
skill as it is with archery painting and
math
he responds does your process not depend
on knowing the main risks
I respond to him not in the way you seem
to imagine I also don't depend on my
knowledge of chemistry to keep me safe
from poisons when I'm in a tropical
forest one could of course treat
everything as poisonous but that's not
what a good naturalist does
you discover patterns and methods
he says
this is where the rubber meets the road
science was invented so you wouldn't do
that I don't even know what that means
so you wouldn't I do so that I wouldn't
have to uh some methods well that's just
the thing interesting you're confused in
exactly the same way that I was so I say
to him fascinating it never occurred to
me that you'd think I was describing an
alternative to science
you have been misled Scott the grant
game has turned universities into a
racket big science is done by people
willing to attest that men can become
pregnant actual science is an art and
then I want to finish on my friend Creon
Levitt who responds
paraphrasing Galileo quote science is
poetry written about nature in the
language of mathematics then he quotes
Feynman for successful technology
reality must take precedence over public
relations for nature cannot be fooled
and then Creon says science is like an
art but unlike art its Supreme Arbiter
is nature and I believe Creon has
slightly misstepped here because I am
saying that the practice of science is
an art I am not saying science is Art
right
okay so what I wanted to do was proceed
from this a little bit I think what is
evident in Scott's complaint especially
where he says
science was invented so you wouldn't
have to do that where I'm saying look I
use something else to figure out where
the toxins are in a tropical forest and
he says science was invented so you
wouldn't have to do this I gotta say
like that I didn't I had not seen this
but if we're reading correctly what
the human is there science is invented
so you wouldn't have to do what you and
I do and we're in tropical forests
I'm not much more scared for Humanity
than I was like I did not think I did
not think that we were there that
actually the Outsourcing of all of the
knowledge including the stuff that
actually people don't yet know was just
like that's that's a good that that's
like oh once once we've got it boxed and
it's been you know peer reviewed uh and
agreed and like rubber stamped well then
boom that's you just look at the you
look at the litany look at the list you
don't use first principles you don't
lose logic you don't keep your brain
alive and be thinking about
possibilities like no that's a known
thing now
that's not that's not ever what science
is supposed to be doing for us right and
so this I thought was a terrific
opportunity because I don't think most
people really understand
what science is you know we could talk
about the scientific method but that's
too narrow that's not what science is at
a meaningful level right right so they
don't really know what it is that we are
claiming and so they do make missteps
like this by the way I forgot to mention
Creon Levitt is a NASA scientist so he
is a professional
um but anyway so I wanted to try a
little thought exercise because I
believe there's some things involved in
what you are called you and I are
calling science that are not narrowly in
the scientific method but are also not
the trappings of science they're what we
actually deploy right and I thought the
following
um thought experiment would reveal it so
the idea not talked to you about this
before because I wanted it to be fresh
but the idea is Imagine for a second
that you and I were traveling by plane
over a tropical forest with which we had
no prior experience like Indonesia for
example we've spent no time in Indonesia
and suppose the plane goes down we
survive and nobody else does okay
so we're now in an Indonesian Forest
okay
um we don't recognize anything from our
direct experience we've never been in
any Forest near there right maybe
there's the occasional plant that's so
General that it has a relative there but
by and large everything would be new to
us and the question is uh well I was
thinking a little bit about the um the
movie The Martian where uh what's his
name Matt Damon Matt Damon at some point
at the point that he's facing that one I
have seen certain death
um uh says that he's gonna he's gonna
science the [__] out of this planet
right which is something you know every
geek in the audience is like yeah
science the [__] out of that thing
um but anyway the point is look you and
I would immediately without ever
mentioning science
start employing the process writ large
to the puzzle presented by well what the
hell are you going to do now that you
are in the situation and I wanted to
talk about what that is because I think
it brings in some of the elements that
Scott is missing here
so all right you got it in your mind
we've landed uh without you know with
some random collection of artifacts that
survived some plane crash nobody's
coming to help us
what do you do how do you engage the
problem
right so a you'd want to think about
what threatens you right and in what
order of priority I'll just be before
you start talking I will say that the
first two thoughts that come to mind are
do we have to engage the question of
cannibalism here
um
not between us no wait like the corpses
nope okay so we don't have to talk about
that you know we could but I don't know
everyone else is okay so we don't have
to go there
um and then you know if it's Indonesia
then of course one of the things that
comes to my mind is like are we on
Borneo or are we on one of the dinky
little Islands such that like actually
we're gonna be out of coast and thinking
about uh you know setting up flares to
get the the attention of other people my
intent here is that we are lost let's
say that you know
you're stuck
Rescuers come you'd see The Rescuers
land uh
and you're you know you're 10 kilometers
out and you book it back as fast as you
can but by the time you get there
they're gone so you can infer they have
decided nobody survived this plane crash
they're not coming back so you know you
have to survive by your wits and this
habitat you don't know right
so anyway a certain number of things
before you get to the sciency part are
like okay what am I threatened by in
this habitat right what is the order of
priority of the problems that I have to
solve
what do I have at my disposal did
anything survive you know
um so let's just take for example
well you've got I mean
you think through the Hostile forces
right the you know the Hostile forces of
nature that that threaten you as a
surprisingly undefended human out in
nature which which doesn't happen to
most humans most of the time but you
know they're the abiotic ones right
there's there's weather and climate now
you're in the tropics so you're unlikely
to freeze to death but
um you know there's there's water levels
that change uh there's tree falls that
can happen that's biotic I suppose and
then over in biotic space you've got you
know people always are like oh you know
what's the big thing that's going to
come at you right like what's what's a
dangerous snake or the big carnivorous
and really those aren't those aren't the
things right so it's going to be
um it's going to be parasites
uh it's and it's going to be
um
chemical competition from Plants it's
going to be like poisonous spines and
thorns and uh and uh and little things
that could get you out of Defense rather
than things that are trying to make you
their lunch right so a couple things one
you're not going to freeze to death but
it doesn't mean you're not going to die
of exposure or short of dying of
exposure you could make problem number
two which is sustenance vastly worse in
other words to the extent that you are
burning hard-won food in order to stay
warm the point is you're actually
require you're you're driving up your
requirements
um for nutrients yeah to the extent that
you could have sheltered yourself and
failed to yeah right so assuming you
have no ability to filter water yep
you you know your your water your water
problem is going to be one uh that shows
up quickly and uh you you want to
carefully basically titrate water intake
uh sufficiently that you can know
relatively quickly is this Source gonna
make me sick
and if so I need to find another source
I would also say that there are some
things you can do to reduce the
likelihood that it's going to make you
sick I mean a you don't want stagnant
yeah you you look for the the clear like
Clarity of water is a good visual
indicator and flow and flow movement and
Clarity are good you know it just has
less particular matter in it it probably
has less stuff that you can't see in it
as well yep
um you could also one of the things that
I would think about doing since water is
unlikely to be limiting but drinkable
water might be
if you could either with something you
Salvage from the wreckage
uh carry small amounts of water so that
you could use UV light to purify them
right a very shallow bit of water can be
purified with UV light now if you're on
the forest floor
it's not like there's no light but it's
not intense right it's it uh I don't
know the Indonesian number when I was
working in Panama there were some plant
physiologists working on questions and
you know they did all kinds of
interesting things like put fisheye
lenses on the floor of a tropical forest
so they could actually monitor the
amount of light over the course of a day
because these light flecks sweep across
the floor as the sun moves right anyway
something like one percent of the
incident light the light that hits the
canopy makes it to the forest floor it's
a tiny fraction well but so you find a
light Gap so you find a place for one of
these um so we're in Indonesia
uh so we're like interestingly one of
the ways it's going to be different from
forest travel for us we've been in is
that most of the trees are from the same
family it's all it's mostly the same is
it different carbs yeah um but still
they're going to fall sometimes so you
find you find yourself a light Gap and
maybe you try to um
UV UV purify water by finding a shallow
pan into which you can put or fashioning
out of some of the fuselage or something
yeah exactly
um and so then you're gonna have to
transport it which is going to be a
waste of time and energy so you're going
to try to get efficient about that
you're going to try to find a get light
Gap or create a light Gap big enough to
do the job and anyway so okay that's
going to be one issue water
obviously for most of your needs it
doesn't need to be drinkable but the
drinkable stuff needs to be pure you
could use UV light
um
okay second thing
food
right so it seems to me that well did
you you said something in that thread
right like I I maybe I inferred because
I know you know I do and you do and you
know we've been together
uh occasionally tasting of neo-tropical
forests
right near tropical neo-tropical forests
tasting in neotropical Forest I said
tasting of tasting of neotropical forest
I would rarely approach a forest and
taste the whole thing but you know the
tasting of not tasting the whole thing
tasting of and uh you know you do so
with
great care and parsimony and
um and a little bit and you wait and you
wait and you wait and you see and a
little bit more of anything now you
can't be as completely careful if you
have nothing if you know if if the when
the plane went down it took out all of
you know if you really have no food at
all
uh you know you have you have some time
but not a ton of time yeah to to figure
out what all you can eat and uh it's
it's tougher to it's tougher to hunt
than people who have never hunted
without the tools that they are
accustomed to hunting with no uh but you
know you learn that but it's far easier
to forage so this is one of the things I
was hoping would emerge here okay
part of what it is to science the [__]
out of a forest like this in order to
survive is taking a model that is robust
figuring out which elements of it apply
to your new situation and then applying
it in a way that you can reverse course
to the extent that you discover
something about the model isn't right
yeah so you and I have a method right
the method involves
the recognition that there are fruits in
a forest especially a tropical forest
those fruits are relatively easily
recognized you can identify a fruit
which does not mean you can eat it okay
some fruits are edible some fruits are
not edible not because they aren't
fruits designed to be eaten but because
the plant in question has decided to
exclude certain animals which are not
good dispersers in favor of other
animals which are this can be
um a trick as it is with chili peppers
where Chili Peppers give you the
impression that you are being damaged
like you're lacerating your mouth but
it's not true that is that is designed
to drive away mammals and give Birds
this particular fruit but they're not
actually poisoning you right but if you
were to find a rando fruit in the
Indonesian Forest that you and I knew
nothing about right some little red
berry hanging off of something yeah
right one thing you could do is you
could take it and you could touch it to
your tongue well but before before you
do that you use your other senses right
um so you'll use the color and say okay
well if it's green actually it's either
not meant for me or it's not ripe yet
probably a no
uh if it's one of the colors that humans
tend to like in fruits okay maybe
although red fruits especially little
red berries are more often bird fruits
oh because birds see birds see red
particularly well you know even in the
in the dark understory
if it has an aroma that smells well
fruity Pleasant if it smells Pleasant to
you as a human being that plant is
communicating to you even if it didn't
know you were coming it knew it was it
was communicating to a potential mammal
disperser of of its seeds and it's
giving you the gift of the fruit to
entice you to disperse it and if it
smells like you know there are in the
Indonesian Forest there are like these
corpse flowers right that attract flies
I guess that's the pollination stage I
don't even know what the fruits of that
plant look like but I'll bet it's not
about mammal dispersal I may be wrong
but like you know if the fruit smells
like poop or a dying corpse like yeah
that's that plant is communicating
something to you and maybe the plant is
trying to obscure that it's got a great
value there and you should override your
first reaction and go for it but don't
start there yeah for example durian
right durian famously has a nasty smell
but it's very good mammal fruit so you
could also you know do something like if
you were to observe monkeys eating a
fruit in a tree and very often there's
fruit dropped at the bottom of the tree
it's almost certain that that fruit is
going to be safe to eat
um from the monkeys invite them to do
well you can follow the monkeys around a
little bit that would be pretty useful
yep totally um your green fruit is a
great uh test case because one
hypothesis is that that green fruit is
not ripe and if you touch it to your
tongue you will get an astringent feel
or a very bitter taste and it will tend
to be hard right so touch as well so
gives you a sense the the key here is
that the model is fruits you shouldn't
eat give you a warning they have an
interest in you knowing very quickly
that you shouldn't eat them because the
whole reason that they're toxic uh is to
dissuade you and this and the the
conversation about fruits is going to be
different from
uh say you know
what else might you find that's not just
a whole organism
um well fungus a fungus right uh no
fungus has as a strategy to disseminate
itself in the world being eaten by
something
I think
I think that there are some occasional
things okay so it's a broadcast
you can assume that you run into a
fungus you might be able to eat it
there's a really good chance it'll kill
you a decent chance it'll get you high
but there's almost no chance if not no
chance at all that its strategy is to
entice you to eat it so that it can it
you can help it with its propagation
into the world whereas there are and we
talk about this in hunter-gatherers
guide the 21st century there are very
few things that we eat that are actually
designed by the organisms to be eaten
and fruit is one fruit milk right and
yeah fruit and milk okay so it's funny
but not by us by the baby but if you can
figure out how to extract it the fact
that I'm just saying like honey honey is
not designed to be eaten by a mammal but
it is designed as food yeah
um okay so your green fruit hypothesis
is and hypothesis doesn't mean I believe
this to be true I mean this might be
true and so obvious it could be but the
point is one hypothesis is that that
fruit is not ripe and that when it is
ripe it will be edible to me yeah it
will be counterproductive if I eat it
before it's ripe now did we have the
foresight to crash uh with flagging tape
or not uh I would really like to Mark
trees well but we're going to get good
at that yeah that's part of the answer
is that the test for the hypothesis that
that is an unripe fruit that I can eat
when it's ripe is to keep checking up on
it right
um the test for the hypothesis that that
fungus is edible to me right might
involve for me I would say watching an
animal that is similar to me
physiologically eat it
um and you know in you know this is a
survival question feeding it to an
animal right right now the question is
how do you feed it to an animal in this
Forest that might be a trick but yeah
that seems like a like that seems
several stages of unlikely but well but
there are ways you could do it you could
pair it with something right also it is
true that many things that are toxic can
be detoxified with methods that you
could innovate here so for example many
of the things like a potato is not a
good thing for you to eat but a potato
that has been boiled is a good thing for
you to eat unlikely to run into potatoes
in the Indonesian Forest no but you may
run into something that is potato-like a
storage organ and the cool place that no
that's also a new world anyway there's
there's some un there's going to be some
underground storage organ right plant is
storing energy for its own use does not
want someone else to come along and eat
it but may have put something in which
could be maybe it's
the proteins are toxin they can be
denatured by cooking them they can
denature them by cooking them or you can
dissolve them out with water those are
the two biggest or dissolve them out
with water and acid or you're right but
um also true that to the extent that
there's some number of calories that you
need
that number can be driven way down with
a technology that you would want for
this other purpose also which is fire so
I would argue one of your top priorities
if you think you're long-term stuck in a
situation like this
is how to make fire now let's say that
nothing from the plane gives us any leg
up in that regard well and you also you
know once once we start talking about
you know how how are we also going to
start getting meat uh which is going to
bring in a lot more calories you then
get a lot more nutrition out of the meat
um once once exactly so no you get more
calories out of the meat once you've
cooked it yeah you get more nutrients
out of the meat especially calories I'm
not I think the the nutrient analysis
may go the other way but you get more
calories
don't think so but anyway it's a it's an
interesting question but in any case you
need a source of fire okay you're in an
Indonesian alolan Indonesian Forest okay
one of the ways to make fire is out you
can't use an ice lens to uh a what an
ice lens the way you would use a
magnifying glass
maybe something from the airplane
yep yeah can be done yes I was not
imagining that you could yeah well it's
it's one of them even on my list of
possibilities okay so that leaves from
my perspective that leaves assuming
nothing from the plane uh is capable you
know there are no lighters or something
like that yeah you've got two options
and I think their priority reverses
based on what you did recover from the
plane
okay the two ways would be bow drill
and fire plow
I don't know what a fire plow is fire
plow is basically a piece of wood that
you rake across a surface that you have
flattened and generate enough heat to
create a spark that can light some of
the fire starting material you know I
just saw a video just before it became
on why I was watching this video I'm not
sure
um this was in this is a an iron guy a a
an iron worker so he's got hard metal
surfaces but uh the the premise is you
know how do you start a fire with
nothing but mechanical force from a
hammer now in this case you've got you
got two pieces of metal so you know you
don't have that necessarily I mean
you've got the fuselage the plane or no
I don't know what all you got um but you
know he's got some Anvil like thing
sorry I don't know the language here
he's got a hammer and he's got some
sticks and some paper and first you know
he
pounds the wood into lots of little
pieces and puts it aside and then he
takes just a like a poker and he just
pounds the poker with the hammer against
the other metal until the poker is hot
enough that it can set the paper on fire
that that can stop the kindling I could
totally see it using mechanical force to
start a fire right and a fire plow
basically allows you to do the something
like this with wood where you generate
enough friction now of course the whole
thing is dependent on I've now forgotten
what the term is for the stuff that you
accumulate that lights very easily
because once you have a little bit of
forest fluff lit then you can wipe
I don't know don't know what Tinder yeah
I guess Tinder is probably the the right
term there may be another term in the
case of of bow drills and stuff but
anyway
um
one of the key things to do one of the
things that I would do first in this
scenario
is find stuff that looks like it should
be flammable and put it in a place that
it will continue to get drier and drier
and drier no matter what the weather
does right because that's going to be
the hard but often you can find stuff
that will burn but it's too wet in the
state that you find it and so yeah um
well and that's you know one of one of
the things one of the things that will
be challenging in such a situation which
won't be obvious to people who haven't
spent a lot of time in lowland tropical
rainforests which say jungles is how wet
everything is even even if it even if
you're in a little mini drought and it
hasn't actually rained for three weeks
and there's no sign that it's going to
rain again it's still just wet
everything is wet and it gets wetter and
so you know the things we haven't talked
about is like how do you keep how do you
keep the fungus away how do you keep the
pathogens away like how do you keep
yourself you know free of the organisms
that want to encroach on you yeah um
that aren't the big charismatic things
that want to bite you and eat you for
lunch but you know it's it's the oh my
foot's gonna fall off because I had a
tiny little wound and now something has
gotten into there and oh gangriness yeah
so it's not your first priority after
the plane crashes but it's very high on
the list that you figure out how to
generate fire and the thing about
generating fire is it's very very
difficult however
it is much easier and I think would be
one of the you know top three or four
jobs in the whole how do we keep
ourselves a live scenario is starting
fire very very tough however many hours
it takes you it's worth it once you've
got the fire started keeping it alive
enough that you can constantly revive it
is going to be the key to survival what
you don't want to have to do is restart
it more times than you need to right you
want to be able to revive it and that
means in this scenario you're going to
have to start banking dry fuel so that
you can keep something on it and if you
have to go out for three or four hours
to go look for food when you come back
there's enough of a smoldering which
also means you need a place to burn it
that if it rains it doesn't suddenly
turn to Mush but anyway you would start
looking for these things
um your point about meat is a good one
of the things you know part of the
scientific model that you would bring to
this forest in which you knew none of
the creatures is the idea that meat is
edible right there are a couple of
mammal species and at least one bird
species that have toxins
as far as I know the pitahui bird is
toxic and I think it's just the feathers
isn't it I'm not sure yeah um but you
know if we crash we wouldn't have we're
not going to crash at a library so you
can't look it up
um okay okay we'll take pitahui off our
list okay if yeah well if we can even
recognize it pitically but the point is
um you know for the ratio of edible
Birds if I remember correctly it's the
same Toxin and I think it's just the
feathers in pitahui as is in the poison
frogs that I studied was that right yeah
it's this these lipophilic alkaloids
that you really don't want to ingest
because uh that's an unpleasant death uh
it would all there are some creatures
that are very
um
distasteful right herbivores we talked
about this full of Wars often take in so
many toxins that their meat is
disgusting yeah um but probably edible
probably okay yeah um but you probably
want to switch to something else as
quickly as possible because the cost of
detoxifying what you would I mean that's
one of the things this is really what
this discussion is about
do you need to reduce your level of
toxins that you take into zero no
your your liver and your kidneys and
other aspects of your physiology can
deal with low levels of toxin what you
don't want to do is take in a lot of any
particular Toxin and certain toxins are
white bat even in tiny amounts which is
why if you if you don't know your fungus
and most people have just don't know
anything close like you that's that that
comes last on your list of dietary
preferences because the toxins that can
that are in so many of the ones that you
that you shouldn't be eating are you
know are enough to hurt you at a very
low dose yeah very low dose you can take
out your liver and there's no coming
back from that in a scenario like this
and it you know frankly even the
hallucinogens are bad for you in this
scenario yeah um because you you can't
afford the confusion
um but that said if you know if
you watched a mammal consume a
significant amount of a mushroom you
could experiment with a tiny amount of
it and see whether it made you sick is
that sure not to kill you I wouldn't say
so but the point is uh a maybe you just
discover you know if it's a fungus and
it's consumed by mammals and you try a
little bit and it doesn't make you sick
hey you may have just increased the
number of things in that Forest you can
eat to something that replenishes that
you can readily recognize it doesn't run
away not very fast at any rate
um so
did you have something else you wanted
to add there so anyway my point here is
science
observe hypothesize predict test is a
smaller piece of a larger picture or
paper repeat repeat repeat but the point
is the whole point of that exercise is
not the production of so-called data
right the the point of the exercise is
the production of models
I don't mean computer models you and I
are both very skeptical of computer
models because it's very easy to fool
yourself or others by adding in enough
parameters that the model uh spits out
plausible sounding answers for no good
reason well and you you add assumptions
in the same way you add data and
generally you're generating neither the
assumptions nor the data and so you've
just like it's not it's not your own
work in the same way it's going like
okay I have my biases and I'm you know
walking around with some assumptions
some of which aren't yet explicit but as
you know as
my hit rate goes down I have to go back
and try to figure out which of my which
what assumptions I don't even know exist
I'm working from and get rid of them one
by one and I mean it's like it's it's
the science version of an Elimination
Diet right
um and and you know figure out what you
need to do to get what your experience
to a greater and greater match for
reality
so
you do this process it generates models
those models are not an exact mirror of
reality and in fact in the scenario that
I picked for us here be very different
if we crashed in a neotropical forest
even a neotropical forest that we didn't
know has congeners of many of the
creatures that we do know yeah and we
know something about their behavior you
know if they're animals which might
allow us to search for them more
narrowly and
um you know you know you and I would
know that a capybara is good eating
right that's something you would know as
for you know a sun bear a how dangerous
is it and B how good is it to eat that's
a tougher one right it's not it's not a
familiar creature to me other than just
to know that it exists
um yeah yeah but you know they like
avocados
Oh no you're talking about spectacle
Bears yeah Oh I thought you were still
in the near tropical forest you're
talking about spectacle bears in the
natural world I was talking about the I
was thinking you could follow spectacle
Bears to the avocados you could follow
well and that's the thing is if we were
in a neotropical forest yeah you know
I would know how to find figs probably
whether you could access them be
dependent on who's feeding on them
because they're too high yeah uh
spondius you know they're all kinds of
things that I would go looking for
quickly but
in a forest I really didn't know you
could you the point is how good is my
model well if I crashed in Brazil it's
better yeah if I crash in you know some
other parts of Sumatra it's worse but
it's not nothing it's certainly good
enough to begin to set out a plan for
how to allocate my time and my effort
and what risks to take in order to solve
the problems that accompany survival
which would be
don't die of exposure don't spend more
energy on staying warm than you need to
don't squander the resources that are in
an animal that you have uh killed by
failing to cook it properly don't risk
taking on the parasites by not cooking
it you know some things that you can't
another reason to cook yep some things
that you can't eat could be rendered
edible if they can be boiled some things
that you can't eat can be rendered
edible if you can cook them the point is
that General model most of those
parameters are not things that we
discovered on our own in a survival
scenario they are things that we have
come about through
studying scientifically through coming
to understand what the underlying
mechanisms is the idea that a plant
might want you not to eat its storage
organ and it might fill it with toxins
but if those toxins are water soluble
that you have a way of extracting them
and leaving the nutrients right this is
the scientific model that you would
crash in the forest with and and in this
case
trusting what your senses are telling
you with regard to aversions and disgust
and preferences and such makes good
sense it that will be a less good guide
the more hyper novel your environment is
but just as we talked about with regard
to fruit you know if it smells good to
you if it if it looks appealing and
smells good and you know feels good in
the hand is less of a thing but like if
it feels ripe because you've eaten fruit
before and you know what ripe tends to
feel like and you taste a little bit of
it and it tastes sweet to you still
don't eat the whole thing all at once
right but if you've got all these other
sensory modalities telling you you know
what this feels right this feels good
there's a really good chance that
um that that is consistent with this is
a fruit this is the fruit of a plant
that benefits When mammals eat the fruit
and disperse the seeds and therefore
this is not going to hurt you because it
was made effectively for you right and
the ability to to override your
intuitive sense of how something smells
or tastes in the case that you have
evidence that it might be all right
anyway is important too so the point is
you crash in the forest in Indonesia
with a crude model and then you use
science to improve that model so that
when you happen onto some durian right
the point is you're not dissuaded by the
fact that it smells bad you know from
having watched a mammal eat it and then
having tried it on your your own and
feeling oh that was pretty good that
that satisfied me and it didn't make me
sick right the point is your model gets
better and better you become expert in
your local habitat and how to
deal with it and so yeah all right I
think we're I think we're more or less
there the point is you've been misled
the degree to which you think that
science is about Laboratories and uh
peer review and studious discussions and
high-tech equipment and that to the
extent that that thing grant money
doesn't work
um you're just [__] out of luck you have
been lied to the proper scientific
thinking is a cultivated way of looking
at the world and you know I was reminded
as I was thinking about us doing this
exercise
that we actually did a podcast back in
Portland in which we talked about this
and we said look you misunderstood
science for us we are much more likely
to be doing science in rubber boots with
machetes than we are to be in a
laboratory or looking through a
microscope doesn't make it less
scientific the point is it's the same
mental process being deployed in a very
different scenario one in which you
cannot drive all of the noise out that's
what a laboratory is it's a noise
remover that allows you to focus in on a
phenomenon and that predicts maybe that
field biologists regardless of whether
they think about Evolution or geology or
ecology or whatever might actually be
better suited to the complexity of
something like a novel coronavirus and a
novel set of vaccines and repurposed
treatments and a political response then
laboratory scientists might be because
laboratory science is precisely about
reducing the number of variables
so that when you get a result you're
more and more confident that it's
because of the thing that you
manipulated whereas field science
can not have most of its variables
controlled so you get accustomed to the
the practice of engaging in a field
science is one in which you have to
figure out on your own what of the vast
amount of noise that I'm experiencing is
actually the pattern that I should be
honing in on and what of it might be
relevant but not right now and what if
it is not what it seems and also I can
ignore it right and
um
so the laboratory is very good at
removing the noise which allows you to
see very subtle
principles yeah you get you you often
get greater Precision you do yeah you do
um and sometimes you need that Precision
in order to see some very subtle
contributor to a process right point is
when somebody says
um I would like to inject you with this
liquid which contains some mRNA messages
which are going to hijack a certain
number of your cells and it's going to
cause them to produce a fragment of a
pathogen and the hope is that that is
going to make you immune if you
encounter that pathogen because it's a
bad one right the point is which is the
better model here the purified
laboratory where the point is oh the
only thing's going on in my experiment
are those tiny few things that I allow
to be there or
the [__] did you just say you're gonna
wait you're new have you ever tested
this on a person have you ever do you
have a successful such a vaccine based
on this technology that you've ever
deployed in a human being how many of
those causal links that you said with
authority are actually black boxes in
which you're kind of crossing your
fingers behind your back going like I
really hope it works the way we say it
does but the fact is that we can't
possibly have the level of certainty
that we claim to which right away tells
anyone who is watching you make the
claims okay
you are at the very least overstating
what you know right why would you be
overstating what you know
let's figure out what you actually could
know and see if you're ever saying some
of the things which you could know huh
also not saying some of the things you
definitely should know at this point
what else is inconsistent and on it goes
right and so you know the
straightforward argument is look you are
talking about introducing something
novel to my physiology
as if you understand my physiology which
I know you don't
nobody understands my physiology not
because I'm special but because human
physiology is complex mostly black boxes
we're very new at this and the degree to
which we understand is far outstripped
by the degree to which we do not yet
understand and so the point is you're
talking about intervening and it's every
bit is idiotic as if you walked into a
tropical forest and said let me explain
to you how this place works
there's oh are you from the future
because nobody in the present knows how
this thing works right we know certain
things but we do not know how this works
and so anyway and yet and yet we can
apply a scientific understanding of the
world and of the forest to have a better
chance of surviving a plane crash there
than if we said well
if I don't have you know if science
doesn't already know exactly what's
going on here I guess I'll just lay down
and die like those are two extreme
responses neither of which is Savvy or
smart or wise yeah now if we ever do
find the scenario unfolding first thing
I'm going to say to you at the point
that we wrestle ourselves free of the
somehow miraculously mostly unscathed
even though everyone else is dead okay
that's what I'm shooting for if that
happens right the first thing I'm going
to say to you is well welcome to complex
systems
probably is yes yes
okay welcome to complex systems here we
go complex systems
[Music]